[Music]
some changes to prevent tragedy an
emergency regulation just passed by the
nevada athletic commission the goal to
make sure nothing like the death of
20-year-old nathan valencia happens
again he died after a fraternity
sponsored charity boxing match it's a
story the i-team first broke hector
mejia joining us now live with the
latest on the effort for oversight
hector
well hey there the last month's charity
event involving valencia was outside the
commission's jurisdiction this is where
they met this morning and they told us
the emergency regulation passed just
hours ago as a first step in protecting
students from similar events in the
future
nevada athletic commission chairman
stephen klubeck said the emergency
regulation now titled nathan's law
closes loopholes that allow fraternities
and similar organizations to evade
oversight and regulation as of 1985
contests of unarmed combat conducted by
or participated by a school or
university were excluded from the
commission's oversight now the five page
document posted on the commission's
website essentially creates a process
for a person to seek and obtain that
exemption it applies to amateur contests
or exhibitions it will be up to future
legislators to determine whether they
wish to make additional statutory
changes on november 19 unlv student
nathan valencia took part in a charity
boxing event held by the kappa sigma
fraternity he collapsed after his fight
and died four days later the i-team
first broke the story and learned there
was no medical help at the boxing match
and valencia's parents say there was no
professional referee unlv kappa sigma
and the athletic commission are still
investigating
commissioners also noted this regulation
does not intend to regulate
organizations such as the ncaa the
regulation now goes to the governor's
desk for for his signature the i-team
right now is working on that part of the
story we'll have the latest starting
today at 4 p.m reporting live hector
mejia live local now hector thank you
metro police saying today no charges
will be filed calling it a tragic death
but not criminal however the richard
harris law firm that represents nathan
valencia's family released a statement
encouraging the state legislature to
close that loophole exempting
universities from the commission's
oversight and also saying in part it
will hold those responsible for lack of
care and management and organization of
the event